I think you've said 20 of all writers
are really good and 10 are great
that's what I saw when I was doing the
HBO access program so
we would get in our
every year we had about 3 500
submissions
to our writers program
and when we did the math
we found that 20 of those
writers were all good they were good
80 of them were probably just not ready
right but 20 were good
and any of those 20 percent
coder should be working in the business
and they came from everywhere all
demographics
10 were really good ten percent are all
people who were very
worthy of of being in the program
so it's not that the talent's not there
the talent's there
and I wonder and I've actually had
conversations with with people before
about this
you just wonder if again the access is
the barrier to entry if yeah there's
there's going to be some part of that
some some piece of that that's going to
be a fraction of those people won't work
in a writer's room they're probably
feature writers or their interest is
someplace different or they want to do
animation we didn't do animation at the
time or
they wanted to do children's and we need
to do children so there may be other
factors that count them out or they're
emotionally not ready to take that next
step which is a very valid thing and I
applaud anybody who understands that
about themselves
but
of those of that 10 percent
those people
again come from everywhere they come in
all ages
and all genders and you just wonder how
many of those people
are out there in the world who just
don't have
the entry point they don't have the
access
and because they don't have that access
they they give up
you know how many people how many
stories are we leaving
on the sidelines
that aren't getting through because
they're not getting the encouragement
which is why when we were doing our
program when we even when we did our
semi-final cut we we put blasted that
information out there because all of
those semi-finalists had jumped over so
many hurdles and
we knew that they were
you know great voices
valued you know
um could be potentially you know working
in this in this industry
and they all needed to be recognized
they all needed their
they all needed their little day in the
sun because what happens is when when
HBO then puts that message out there all
the Agents come looking for them they
see their names they're like hey we look
them up online and reach out directly
and all those people get them a little
bit of lift
but yeah there's a lot of talent out
there
you just wonder how many stories haven't
been told that should be told
you say emotionally ready what does that
mean when I say emotionally ready I mean
that sometimes you can get to a place
where
you have the path the door is open to
you
but you aren't necessarily ready for all
that it entails being a working writer
in this industry is not easy once you've
gotten the gig it's you still putting in
hours and you're still writing on the
side because you need another piece of
material
and you still have to work with other
people in a writer's room right on the
TV side or you still have to navigate
what it means to be a writer and you and
sometimes that the not knowing where
your next meal is coming from is not
easy to to understand or to to stomach
and then there are other things so
whether you are you know this about
yourself or you don't you in order to
sit in a writer's room and to contribute
without over contributing
um
sometimes we don't all have the same
skill set emotionally we don't have the
right tools emotionally to take all that
on it is a it is a thing
so that's when I say
emotionally you have to be ready for it
because once you are stepping onto that
train as a working writer
it can be a lot
there have been times where people come
out of a program and they go you know
what I'm not going to be I realized in
the program that I don't love this
process
and I would rather go direct or I would
rather go write novels or I'm actually
not fitting I don't see myself fitting
into this world in this way
or I'm dealing with my own stuff and
it's hard to deal with that I need to
take a break or I need to take a step
back and that's okay not everybody gets
to this the starting line at the same
time
and I do think that what we ask of
writers is an emotional work and if
you're not ready to expose that
you got to do it at your own pace
because you can damage your soul if you
are not ready
so you have to figure out a way to be
okay with it and remember you're getting
criticism constant criticism
whether people are saying it in a nice
way or not and how you internalize that
and if you're okay with that
then you're good to go
and if you internalize that you cannot
you cannot make sense of it and you need
to do some emotional work then sit it
out for a minute
until you're ready
so
do you think that's a rare individual
who realizes wow this big door is open
for me and I'm actually not ready and
I'm going to turn it no I don't think
it's unusual because I've I've
encountered quite a few people who who
get that who know who understand that
and and I think that when you've got to
that place where you are people are
starting to set those meetings it clicks
in pretty quickly your fight or flight
goes oh the the sensors go off pretty
fast
like I don't think I can do this this is
making me too uncomfortable
so I do think that there's a little bit
of a pressure point that just goes
Haywire
and that's good then then you gotta
figure out another way
and do you think because so many of
these writers they hone their craft
outside of school on their own whether
at the library coffee shop in the room
and now it's a totally new ball game
with input and agendas and personalities
and they weren't prepared for that
well I think also remember that uh
beyond all that and that might be that
might be true
sometimes when you get into a writer's
room and you are dealing with a lot of
criticism
and you let's just say you have a funky
writer's room which a lot of people we
saw in the last couple years a lot of
people had to go through there's a
misogyny there's racism you know there's
uh there's so many other things that are
coming at people
that have nothing to do with the work
sure teacher's pet
you got to figure out a way to hold on
and I had a conversation with a with a
writer Kathleen McGee Anderson I had a
had a breakfast
um at the Beverly Hills was it Beverly
Hills Deli what's the one that's at the
top of Van Nuys whatever that Delhi was
Beverly Glendale years ago and this was
back when she had just wrapped Lincoln
Heights and she said I'm really
concerned that that we are losing a lot
of our black female writers that they
just can't
that it's so hard to be in a room and
you're the only one and so we started a
group and we got and we did it for a
couple years where we got I was an NBC
at the time we got a lot of senior level
we had I think three or four senior
level writers brought a
mid-level and a junior writer and it was
to Foster more mentoring
and to give them some place where they
could they could a soft place of land
essentially a a touch point
because we needed people to wrap their
arms around the people who are coming up
and go oh yeah they're going to call you
the diversity higher whether you were or
not they're gonna
try to shame you into that
and they're going to want to touch your
hair and they're going to want to throw
Rachel up that said to you and they're
going to want to you know push your
buttons and they're gonna try to
undermine you and that was just very
very common probably still is
and navigating that takes a lot of
emotional fortitude
now I've been the diversity gal so I've
had a lot of stuff slung at me I don't
I've got tougher skin than a lot of
people
so I think I could probably weather it
but it wasn't easy getting there there
was a lot of times that I would go home
and just be emotional wreck because
nobody wanted to see that coming nobody
wanted to see the diversity person come
in because I was always there to tell
somebody that they're racist and they
probably were
but then I wasn't the you know I wasn't
very well liked in that role personally
I could be have friendships with them
but but they're not looking for that
right they're not looking for that
criticism
so it gave me a tougher skin than maybe
some other people added as a network
executive I had to be had a tough skin
so
um
but not everybody starts there you
develop that as you go along you created
you know
can you develop it without becoming
bitter
oh sure I think you can I think
I think it's hard I think there are
times when you're dealing with it but
but that's a bigger that's a bigger
question because
you know it it goes Way Beyond Hollywood
we're living in a time when we are
seeing the rise of it but we never
really left it we you know my parents
went through the 60s and and
so there's always been Strife there's
always been struggle before that we've
we've we've had struggle here for you
know 400 plus years that's not going to
go away and then
mix in every other culture that's tried
to assimilate here and try to get a
foothold
so there's going to be a sense I mean
what what does James Baldwin say to be
black man black to be black in America
is essentially to be in a rage all the
time there's like I'm paraphrasing
terribly but to be in a rage all the
time and that's of course that's part of
it it's an undercurrent because we are
looking for fairness in a place that
fairness doesn't exist nor does anybody
want there to be fairness
you know the people who should be should
be fair are not fair right
so we're constantly struggling we're
constantly looking for a place to exist
peacefully and do the best of work that
we can against
terrible terrible odds
but that's part of it that's part of
where we are I I I've
I had a conversation the very first
conversation with
with my boss at NBC one of an amazing
woman named Paula Madison and she sat me
down for lunch and she said though
almost the very first thing she said at
this lunch it's so seared in my brain
was she said make no mistake this is a
civil rights job
this is civil rights that's what we're
doing in diversity right
and I think of my role as a diversity
executive and and I think in in my
place in that world
it's funny because a a young man just
asked me about this recently in the last
couple weeks and I said we are part of a
chain we are just one Link in a chain
the change stretches out way far behind
us and Away in front of us and we're not
going to fix this In Our Lifetime won't
be over
but we are doing our part because we
cannot allow the chain to break we have
to keep going right
so if you think about all the people who
came before us there's been
terrible terrible atrocities and I know
we're going we're like going off script
here right and our conversation but
terrible terrible things have happened
and we keep standing on the shoulders of
those who come before us so I'm standing
on the shoulders of of my boss and her
predecessors and a long Legacy of people
and there will be people who stand on my
shoulders as well
so yeah there's going to be some
bitterness because it's not fixed yet
but that there's also a lot of
other things that come into my daily
existence I'm not all bitter that's not
my I don't wake up feeling bitter
I wake up and I
do the job that I'm tasked to do I
create material hopefully I come to the
material and try to
create something that then again you are
touched by that then bridges that gap
between US just a little bit more and
that's the job that's my job right now
so
you can't you can't live on bitterness
you have to get up and do your job every
day you gotta go
make something happen
so there's a there's a time and a place
to to be angry and to fight back but
then there's another time and a place to
say okay I'm just going to focus on the
task at hand and I'm not going to but
they might be one of the same
they might be the one in the same
so every single script that I write has
a black lead
black female lead so far
um I actually had a conversation with a
friend of mine who was like she was
reading my scripts she's really really
great
um uh
um I don't know she she helps a lot of
people with their material and and I
hadn't written in like my description
that the lead was black and she says
well you have to write that in
she said otherwise we assume it's white
and I said why would you assume that
why would you assume that it's coming
from me and a lot of other writers that
I know who are of color were like why
would you assume that
um
but that assumption is really like it
just gets it gets to me I'm like
don't ever assume that about me you
should have to assume the opposite
and that if I tell you that the
character is white then
it's white
but again I feel like there's like all
of this stuff that goes into
um
into how I'm presenting my material my
material is by its very nature
advancing the cause
it's putting another perspective out
there it's showing you that this other
care this character can be whoever she
is and navigate the world so that's part
of it it's all part of it and by the way
the first script that I wrote that got
into Sundance was all about bitterness
she the character was like a Joy Reed
kind of character and she was on a
terror the whole time and I likened it
to being how I sound in my head all the
time that's not every character I have
not every character's like that but
there's an element of just by that
character existing in the world just by
people reading that script just by who's
who I'm putting out there that's also
advancing the cause